you telling the story about what
happened in between that about what Remy
did to his stuff what's that oh yeah
bring that up dark side well yeah this
is what this is this is she when she
goes to sleep she goes it's just to look
at me she goes take both the dogs down
right before you go to bed and at that
time you couldn't leash him at the same
time I bring I'm done yet to go one at a
time
I live in a third they just good to wild
because I go to sleep earlier than him
yeah so I always say if you're awake in
four hours can you please take the dogs
down for one last P so that they don't
have to hold their bladders for eight
hours right mhm so that night go be our
dog was acting crazy like she kept
wanting to go out maybe that she had
diarrhea so I just kept going down there
would go be right and then by the time
five o'clock came around she's asleep
dead asleep in a ball next to kalila I
lost weight to her tomorrow
yeah so as I said like she asked so I'm
slowly getting into bed and she wakes up
and she goes did you bring him down Remy
I go no because she was sleeping he was
sleeping I told you to bring him down
right yeah and then Remy gets up gets on
the ground and now her mom had just
cooking in the house but I have my
jacket my leather jacket my blue bag all
in a little pile
Remy walks up to it opens his leg and
pisses all over myself and why he chose
your stuff now I'm pissed cause I'm like
if you had just taken him down that
wouldn't have happened but he's also
pissed because his entire backpack is
wet Reza was he about the red zone oh he
was he was on the side of the bed for a
whole hour that's all you hear is just
red zone breathing and then she and then
she will no but she's like you want to
talk about it
what did I say it made him even more a
yeah what I cycle I'm just doing with
myself was my fault like it or age you
know yeah he's a crafty little guy huh
sometimes I just wish that he would
listen to me I only brought the doc in
first at that point I didn't love Remy I
wanted the little guy out of the [ __ ]
house not attached to me at that time
I'm sorry don't get angry to me it was
like that's her situation and I always
deal with me and that's exactly what she
did but now I love the guy party I'm
taking him down okay yeah he got to me
because now when I come in the house
he'll walk her right up to me and put
his paws on my knees what is he saying
look you know go like that and I'll go
hey cholo I don't know you guys we
really need to find Remy a home and
somebody who can appreciate the bus a
magic grandpa who likes to run away
sweet he's so sweet yeah and also um we
you'll have a relationship with us too
because we want to see Remy again if you
want to get connected to the Indus what
a me Bobby let me I'm doing everything I
got right and it will be not you won't
just be a fan of the podcast you'll be
family
what's a criteria though you guys gonna
interview these people I got to do a
home check now
I like their fences
[Music]